next stop is better tea table schemes
for consumers with evolving values
thanks Amit and thanks everyone for
coming this is a joint work with pretty
much the same team as the last talk so
Anna and Nick Hill over there and Baloo
seven okay so one main message of my
talk today is that uncertainty can be
hard to model so this is the
optimization understand uncertainty
workshop so the message fits in that way
and it it makes sense for our community
to think about approaches where we can
come up with solutions that are robust
to our modeling of this uncertainty and
this is very much along the lines of
what Tim was talking about yesterday but
we will apply it in a slightly different
context so this talk is about mechanism
design and mechanism design is driven by
lack of knowledge or lack of information
so let's think of a simple setting where
we have a seller selling an item a few
buyers show up and the seller wants to
maximize his revenue but doesn't know
how much the buyers are willing to pay
for the items and the buyers may not
know each other's preferences and so the
mechanism design problem is about trying
to elicit this information so as to
achieve the objective and the seller has
a lot of degrees of freedom by which he
might obtain this information so it
might run or auction might use
randomness you know sell items or
bundles of items or sell lotteries over
items and so on so there's a lot of
different things that this mechanism can
do in order to obtain the information
and yet in many different cases we find
that you know you don't actually need to
use all of these different degrees of
freedom in order to get a good
approximation so
many times there are these posted price
mechanisms that work really well get a
good approximation one example is Anna
stock earlier and Matt is going to talk
about similar stuff later today and
these poster pricing mechanisms despite
their simplicity or maybe because of
their simplicity are tend to be pretty
robust to you know changes in the in the
prior in the input little changes to the
model whereas the optimal mechanism
might not be so robust so that's that's
a nice property to have now I'm gonna go
and add more uncertainty to the setup so
let's imagine that you have the seller
and now a single buyer but this buyer is
gonna show up every day and buy
something from the seller and as before
the seller doesn't know the buyers value
in fact the seller doesn't know what the
buyers value is gonna be tomorrow or the
day after and so on and here the buyer
may not know what his value is going to
be tomorrow the day after and so on and
so the protocol that they engage in
today both the seller and the buyer have
are going to strategize depending on
what their beliefs are about how the the
buyers value and preferences are gonna
evolve in the future
okay so this brings in more degrees of
freedom for the mechanism designer you
can do more interesting stuff you have
to be very careful in that in this
setting the buyer is now facing some
risk as to what's gonna happen in the
future and you have to make some
assumption about how the buyer reacts to
that risk so the seller may not know
whether the buyer is you know risk
neutral or is seeking or risk-averse and
in fact the the buyer might not know
himself so if I offer you a lottery that
pays you ten dollars with 50%
probability how much are you gonna be
willing to pay for it you know five
dollars four dollars three dollars
I'm sure everyone has a different answer
for how they assess the value of such a
lottery and if you know if it's a more
complicated distribution it's not easy
for a buyer and an individual to assess
for themselves how much this this kind
of risk is worth to them and in fact
it's even harder to make decisions that
are consistent across different kinds of
lotteries and so so risk is something
that's a very tricky to model correctly
okay and so this is this is one way in
which uncertainty creeps into the system
and the thrust of this talk is that in
this kind of setting it can be possible
to design mechanisms and again these are
going to be posted pricing type
mechanisms that are robust to this sort
of uncertainty about the behavior of the
buyer okay so that's the main message
okay so let me be more specific about
the kind of problem that we study and
it's a it's a stylized model so we're
going to imagine that the seller has an
app to sell and the buyer is gonna you
know use this app multiple times and the
buyer doesn't know how what his value
for the app will be in perpetuity
instead his value could evolve in fact
as a function of his experience with the
app so the buyer uses the app one day
enjoys the experience his value goes up
for the next use and then the next day
it's it's not quite as enjoyable and the
value goes down after some time the
buyer me all together tired of using the
app and so his value goes down to zero
and he stops using it okay and and one
question that we might think about here
is what is the item or the product that
the seller is trying to sell is the
seller selling you know unlimited use of
the product or a single
the use of the product what is the item
that we want to price is it promise of
future availability you know it a
membership type model there there's
there's a huge number of different
things that one might do here okay so
let's let's formalize all of this and so
for those of you who are not familiar
with mechanism design here's a quick
introduction to how you might formalize
this so in a single short setting when
you have just the seller who just has a
single item to sell and the buyer has a
value for this item let's here's how a
typical mechanism design protocol plays
out so the seller is going to learn the
distribution for the buyers value and
based on this he's going to announce an
allocation function and a payment
function and then the buyer is gonna
draw a value from this distribution he's
gonna bid some amount in the mechanism
and then the seller is gonna sell the
item with probability this a Lukie if
this function x applied and B and at
price B of B okay and the property that
we want is if the buyer looks at his
utility from the sale so this utility is
his value times the probability he got
the item minus the price he had to pay
then these functions are pegged in a
manner that this utility is maximized by
the buyer reporting his value truthfully
so it's maximized at B equals B and
subject to this constraint I see here
stands for incentive compatibility we
want to maximize the expected payment
that the borrower makes okay so what
about the repeated the dynamic setting
well here again so on the first day the
game plays out in pretty much the same
way the buyer draws a value from the
distribution for the first day reports a
bid and then the seller picks some
allocation functions some payment
function now the next day though
the buyers value might be drawn from a
distribution that depends on what
happened on the first day and again he
reports a pair and this time the seller
again picks some X 2 and P 2 and this
again depends on everything that the
seller has seen so far okay and likewise
on day I you know all of these V's and
X's and peas depend on everything that's
happened in the past okay
and what are the properties that this
mechanism should satisfy so it again
needs to satisfy some kind of incentive
constraint so let's think of the buyers
utility on the eyuth day this is this
function here and so the sellers
constraint should be that if the buyer
looks at his total utility from that
accrues over time and then this should
be maximized yeah it depends on how you
define the price but let's say that the
bar here P is irrespective of the yeah
and then the seller again wants to
maximize the payment that he gets from
the system okay so this is one way of
formalizing this problem and some of you
might have noticed that I sneaked in an
assumption here without stating it which
is that the buyer is risk neutral so as
soon as I put an expectation here there
is a risk neutrality assumption that I
made did you have a question
okay so good question so we are actually
not going to closely look at this model
but this is the assumption that goes
into this sort of work if you start to
write down a model you assume you know
everything about how the value evolves
how the process evolves and then for and
just in order to be able to
mathematically formalise this you make
assumptions of the sort that the buyer
is receiver or you make a different
assumption but you write down a precise
mathematical model of what that is okay
and this is there there's a whole ton of
work on these dynamic settings and this
is the sort of approach that this work
takes and in fact some of this by people
that are present in the audience and
it's it's beautiful work and these are
really challenging problems they're
non-trivial even in the simplest
settings so for example even if the
values on different days are are
independent because of this you know
revelation of information that's
happening over time the mechanism design
problem becomes complicated and one
needs to make these strong assumptions
in order to obtain any sorts of results
such as that the buyer is risk neutral
and it requires the seller and/or the
buyer to solve these complicated MDPs in
order to be able to solve this problem
so it's it's really not a desirable
state of affairs and what might we ask
from a satisfying solution to this
problem well hopefully it's simple to
compute and implement which the previous
kind of model is not you know you would
want I want it to be details free in the
sense that we don't have to make you
know very fine grained assumptions about
exactly how the value evolves for
example among
other things hopefully not very many
assumptions about the buyer stress and
attitude towards risk and you should
still be able to approximate optimal
revenue so I've just put down you know
what would be the best case scenario
here and the message of this work is
that under a very stylized model it is
actually possible to achieve all of
these okay and I'll show you the model
where it's possible to achieve this okay
okay so that's sort of the very
high-level picture now let me say a few
words about the specific model so we're
going to assume that so again this is
the the AppStore setting the buyer is
going to buy an app to use and then use
it for some amount of time we'll assume
that there's some distribution for the
buyers initial value and the value is
always bounded within some range and the
value is going to involve by having a
random shock added to it at every step
and we're gonna assume that this the
value of a stay is bounded so it never
goes beyond one and once it reaches zero
it gets absorbed at zero that's like
saying the buyer loses interest in this
product okay okay and what is our
mechanism gonna do we gonna so in the
interest of simplicity we're going to
assume that the seller announces a per
usage price for this product and this
price could look like you know some sort
of varying price over time okay
and so the seller specifies precisely
how much the buyer needs to pay for
every subsequent use of the product
ahead of time and then we're gonna so we
need to make some assumption about how
the buyer reacts to this price we gonna
assume that the buyer buys the product
as long as his value
stays above the price announced for that
particular usage okay so recall that the
value it was stochastically as long as
the the value at that point of time is
above the price announced for that point
of time the buyers gonna buy once the
value goes below this price we don't
make any further assumptions about what
the buyer might do he might continue to
buy or not but we're not gonna account
for that for the revenue from that so we
call the total revenue accrued up to
this point as the sellers risk robust
revenue okay and this is what we want to
analyze we still won't account for the
revenue from that okay and so what do we
want to compare this against so we give
it a gonna give all kinds of advantage
to the optimal solution here so we're
gonna assume that the optimal solution
knows what the starting value is and so
the optimal solution so the optimal
mechanism could potentially look at the
total value that the buyer could accrue
over the entire process and charge the
buyer exactly that and the you can
imagine in some state of the world where
this might make sense and so we call
this the cumulative value of the buyer
and this is gonna be what we compare our
risk robust revenue against okay so
pictorially the blue area here is the
risk robust revenue that this pricing
achieved and if we let the value evolve
until it goes all the way down to zero
then the red shaded area here is the the
buyers cumulative value and we want to
come up with the pricing where the blue
approximates the red okay that's the
goal yeah
I'm gonna come to assumptions that go
into the theorem yeah okay so this is
what we want to do blue approximates the
red we want to come up with this pricing
now pictorially here the seems like
somewhat of a daunting task and let me
give you an example where a very simple
pricing is not going to achieve a good
approximation here so let's suppose that
the the buyers value evolves according
to a simple random walk with some fixed
step size and we could have so let's let
V be this initial value and we're gonna
consider this class of pricings where
the seller just announced is a constant
price P for the item for every time step
and observe here that the buyers
cumulative value is going to look like
it's going to be linear in V and and one
over the square of the step size so you
can this is easy to compute by writing
down a series of equations this is a
simple random walk and so you solve
these you get V over Delta squared for
the cumulative value on the other hand
if you look at how long the this
mechanism accrues this risk robust
revenue this depends on how long this
random walk takes to hit this price P
and so we can analyze that because this
is a simple random walk there is
reflection at one happening but we can
you know unfold the random walk around
one think of this as a random walk
between zero and two and then ask how
long does it take for this random walk
starting at B to hit P or to minus B and
that's a simple expression it's
basically this length times this length
divided by Delta squared so about you
know V V minus P over Delta squared
that's what it turns out to be and so
the risk robust revenue is basically P
times this okay and now even if we knew
what the starting value V was the best
we can
do is to set P to be let's say V over to
one this gives us risk robust revenue
that's V squared over Delta squared and
you can see that there's there's a gap
between the cumulative value and the
risk robust revenue and this depends on
the starting value V if V is tiny then
this gap is large okay so we don't want
that so what this example shows that
even for a simple random walk the if you
if your solution is just a constant
price then you cannot hope to achieve
the kind of theorem that I want to
achieve okay okay so what can we do then
so we're going to show that you don't
need to make things too much more
complicated beyond just a single price
so here's what the solution looks like
we're going to offer the item for free
to the buyer for the first few time
periods and then we're gonna charge a
fixed price okay so this is just a free
trial period where the the buyer gets to
try the item and see how much he likes
it and then there's a fixed price there
on okay and we're going to analyze this
under a model where the value evolution
is a martingale let me go through these
this model in some more detail so I
already mentioned that the value is
bounded between 0 and 1 and there's
absorption at 0 and then this follows
the martingale property and we make the
assumption that the the step size for
this martingale is bounded so epsilon is
a bound on the step size at every step
and it also has some minimum variance
okay and for our result all of these
turn out to be essential
however the value is bounded above by
one yes so the martingale property holds
yes so the martingale property holds
whenever the value is strictly between
zero and one but not at one that one it
bounces back that's right so there's we
need two yes so you're absolutely right
that this step size needs to be relaxed
when the value is very close to one so
there are some more technical things
that go into it when you get very close
to one yeah oh yes yeah this was
supposed to be VP plus one yes yeah
thanks yeah so it is a martingale this
one doesn't look like it okay so what is
the theorem so the theorem is that if
you have a martingale process with these
epsilon and Delta values so there's an
upper bound and Miniver and lower bound
on the step size then we can come up
with this kind of pricing where we have
a free trial period and then a fixed
price that obtains an approximation to
the cumulative value that depends on the
ratio of epsilon and Delta and
furthermore the C and T here depends
only on epsilon and Delta and it
suffices to have estimates for these
quantities and we don't need to know
anything else about the martingale
process at all okay so in particular the
value evolution can depend on the entire
history and we don't need to know any
details about that as long as we have
estimates for epsilon and Delta we can
get this approximation yes if you don't
know Epsilon is there any way
I don't know I don't know you need to
know this to be able to so let me show
you the proof and it'll become clear a
little bit at the very beginning so you
we announced this entire pricing at the
beginning okay and observe that we are
seeing nothing here about what the
initial value distribution is so the
initial value distribution can be
completely arbitrary okay so a couple of
comments before I show you the proof
really quickly so so even when this
initial value is known sort of
buy-it-now approach where you try to
price the usage at the very beginning is
not gonna get this sort of theorem what
this pricing lets us do is to price
discriminate while still being envy free
and it also gets a larger market share
than a kind of mechanism that tries to
price the product in the beginning so
I'll go very quickly past this yeah try
period is to make the value relu
intuition behind yeah the idea of the
free trial period is that even if you
start with a very low value there is
still a small chance that it's gonna
pick up you're gonna start liking the
item and it lets this do that so let me
show you a very quick proof for the
simple random walk and then some
intuition for the general martingale
case and in the simple random walk the
idea is basically that you know we want
the free trial period to be long enough
so that this value that starts out
really low has a good chance of climbing
up to a high value before we start
charging the the buyer anything at all
okay so just to put some numbers here
recall from
it's so this is these are some easy
facts about random walks if you look at
the probability that this random walk
starting at a value of V is gonna reach
one before it reaches zero this is
exactly we okay this is just a simple
consequence of optional stopping and
then we can also compute the expected
time taken to reach this high value
condition on the fact that it reaches
this high value and this turns out to
depend on the step size so it looks
something like constant times one over
Delta squared and then once it climbs up
to this high point the time that it
takes to get down to a price of C is
also about one over Delta squared okay
so the thing we want to achieve from our
pricing is that we want this event to
happen before we start charging the
agent okay and then but we want it to
happen you know but we want to start
charging the agent early enough so that
we have enough time to make some revenue
okay and there's a choice for this
capital t that allows us to do that so
if we set T to some constant times one
over doesn't squared and C to some
constant then there's a constant
probability that if the if the value
indeed climbs up to one then we're gonna
be able to charge the buyer for long
enough to be able to make some revenue
okay so we put all of that together we
get that with probability Omega off we
we get revenue constant over Delta
squared and recall that the cumulative
value here was V over Delta squared and
so these are within constant factors
okay so that's a very rough argument for
what happens in the simple random walk
case okay now what goes wrong with this
true for a general martingale is that
when this this value is climbing up
this might happen rather slowly
okay now the martingale recall has an
upper and lower bound on its step size
and these could be quite different and
so it could happen that you know it
lines up to a high value very very
slowly but on its way down it's really
fast okay so we're trying to capture
revenue from this really short interval
you know the high value to down to the
price and this is a short interval and
where this interval begins has a large
variance okay so it's it's really tricky
to set a length for this free trial free
period in just the right way so that we
capture the revenue from that short
interval okay so that's that's the
tricky part with a general martingale
but the way we do it is instead of
thinking about you know instead of
setting it up so that the value climbs
all the way to one very before the free
trial period ends we look at some some
smaller value that's above the price
that we're going to charge but then we
set this we look at this sort of
checkpoint
in such a way that this checkpoint is
achieved quickly okay and so this time
around let me be quick here we're going
to look at three different events so
we're going to look at this initial part
of the process where we're trying to
argue that with some probability the
value is going to climb to this
checkpoint W before the free trial
period ends and then we're going to look
at this next stage where we say that
there's a good probability that this
value will keep climbing all the way up
to one before it goes down to the price
C and then we're going to exploit this
third phase of the process where the
value now takes some time to go down to
two all the way to the price okay so we
break up the analysis into these three
components and again much of this
analysis is based on the
stopping theorem and you know analyzing
just the right functions of this
martingale process so it's all very
elementary and it works out nicely and
we get this property that all of these
good events these checkpoints are
achieved with probability that's linear
in V and then we get revenue that looks
like Delta over epsilon cubed with the
right choice of parameters and again the
buyers cumulative value is V over Delta
squared and so the ratio then becomes
this function of Delta over epsilon okay
so that's that's very quickly what the
argument looks like so let me just
conclude saying that I showed you a very
stylized model of this dynamic mechanism
design problem the high level thing to
take from this is that in in many such
complicated settings you can find simple
mechanisms that are not only
approximately optimal but also robust to
knowledge about you know the robust to
modeling decisions or information about
the input and in this case it's also
robust to the virus risk attitude and I
want to leave you with two thoughts one
is that you know we should value this
kind of robustness I think and the
second is that there's this perplexing
thing in mechanism design that we see
many different settings where these
posted price mechanisms perform really
well and you know it's it's a little bit
perplexing in that we don't need to use
you know all of the different degrees of
freedom that we have in the in this
optimization problem and yet we end up
doing so well so I wonder if there's
some meta theorem here for why these
posted price mechanisms work so well
thank you
so you should if the jumps are
independent if you have rather what to
get constant so we can also show that if
the jumps are independent of the current
value so you know the step sizes are all
different over time and the
distributions of the shocks could be
different but but are independent of the
of VP then you can shave off or Delta or
epsilon factor but I don't know how to
do better no no no the random walk the
step size is the same throughout time so
you can have different step size and
also it doesn't have to be you know plus
Delta or minus Delta it can be a totally
different distribution with mean zero
but as long as it's independent of VT
then you can shave off another factor so
you can do that so I I'm not sure that
this trick martingale condition is
really necessary to achieve this but we
don't know if techniques to really go
beyond that did you have a question
we're the lower bound and upper bound on
the step size that cannot achieve a
constant approximation thank you
you mean independent of the parameters
this simple type of pricing in that
regime is so we do have some interesting
examples I can tell you more offline
yeah but but the the lower bound and
upper bound on the process is necessary
without which we cannot get results so
in some sense the the the ratio the
approximation also necessarily depends
on these lower and upper bounds yeah